well right now a man faces a murder  charge after a shooting that actually  happened inside a bar  24 year old anthony balderas is accused  of  walking up to the victim shooting him  and then leaving that bar  early sunday morning he appeared in  court for the first time this morning  this all happened at pt's place near  charleston in decatur  police say there was actually no  interaction between balderas and the  victim  inside that bar before the shooting when  confronted by officers balderas  allegedly said  he didn't recall anything about this and  he actually apologized  right now we don't know the name of the  victim